duncan robinson of my miami heat as they
pick up the wind last night he had 18
points
and uh they all came from three-point
range six at 12 and uh they pick up the
win
and now game three between the celtics
and heat will be
on espn that'll be coming up this
weekend good morning duncan how are you
feeling today
uh good morning thanks for having me on
feeling good obviously
um nice to get that game too um but
looking forward to prepping for game
three today
if somebody hadn't watched the miami
heat play how would you describe this
team
uh probably in one word i would just say
grit um you know we have a lot of guys
that just carry that chip on their
shoulder um it's something that we
definitely pride ourselves on and uh you
know we're going to try to bring it for
all 48 um and if it takes more than 48
minutes then then so be it so
we're on selfish share the ball um and
just compete on both ends of the floor
what have you learned from jimmy butler
a whole lot uh first and foremost um
you know it's pretty uncommon to have a
superstar that's so
unselfish who doesn't care about shot
attempts and
literally just cares about winning he'll
do whatever it takes to win and
uh if that's sacrificing his attempts
and and maybe his
uh you know points in the point column
um for assists rebounds
guarding uh he'll do it he just he does
whatever it takes to win and
he's certainly our leader and we just
all kind of fall in line and
and follow what are you taking advantage
of with the celtics
they're they're a tough team um you know
they're incredibly talented
offensively in particular so we're just
trying to mix it up
throw different things at them kind of
keep them keep them out of rhythm uh
because
you know you've seen it in stretches
when they get in rhythm they're really
hard to guard so
uh we just try to make it difficult on
them on that end and then play to our
strengths on offense
um you know put pressure on the rim
shoot threes um
and get to the free-throw line that's
that's basically our offensive identity
i love what you guys did against
milwaukee and
came on the show and said don't be
surprised if the heat beat the milwaukee
bucks because you guys play great
defense
you know tran you kept milwaukee out of
transition by the way the greek freak
just won his second mvp so that just
came over
but you guys frustrated him and that
entire team
but now it's a kind of a different
philosophy with the celtics it's not
based off
just one player there but i'm impressed
bam adebayo is right in front of us
becoming a
you know he's a great player and really
extremely talented how surprised are you
with what you've seen with bam honestly
not very surprised um you know he's he's
been doing it for us
all year he made huge steps this year um
but a lot of that was was just kind of
like structurally um just roster wise he
had more opportunity
last year you know he showed it um game
in and game out
maybe not as in the same sample size
that everyone's seeing now but
um he's so dynamic and people think of
versatility as
the ability to shoot threes but um he
doesn't do that for us yet i mean he
certainly could but
he he does so much more for us
offensively we run so many things
through him and then defensively his
versatility
um i really think it's been on full
display this playoff switching ball
screens and protecting the rim and
um you know we say it all the time
jimmy's our leader
jimmy and gorham but but bam is really
the heart and soul um and he he brings
it for us every single night
does tyler hero talk trash every game
yeah i mean it's it's it's just kind of
who he is you know he plays with that
chip that confidence and uh it's not
necessarily like sometimes just directed
at people
individuals um but sometimes it's just
kind of him him talking to himself or
to us just to kind of get him in that
zone um because when he gets there you
know he's
he's just so tough um and he just has
this kind of unshakeable confidence
about him especially for a young guy
it's really impressive what do you do on
an off day in the bubble
uh rest recover and then you know go
over some adjustments prep
get some shots up maybe a lift depending
on you know
what day of the week it is but just get
ready you know at this time of the year
it's just
all about um the next task just keep on
checking the boxes
and um you know trying to win another
game who makes the bed
ah we we got uh the people here at
disneyland okay you don't do that right
i mean i actually i try to that's that's
my sad excuse
wait that that's you trying to do it
because you knew you were going to be on
camera
yeah i mean that's my course my mom
would be disappointed in that effort
um but uh we we got people here at
disney lookout for us which is much
appreciated but
i try to make my bed in the morning do
you watch football on sunday as a group
yeah yeah absolutely it was great to to
watch uh
those games last sunday and monday and
actually a group of us watched
the game last night at least the second
half of the game last night which is fun
what
what's your favorite team so
so truthfully i i actually grew up a
patriots fan
um so i have some allegiances there but
uh i've also kind of turned into a
dolphins fan as well just being down in
south florida
so it's kind of it kind of cuts both
ways i know that's that's tough answer
concern they played each other last week
um but i kind of opted out of that game
and i'll root for both teams moving
forward
who would be the best football player on
the heat roster
i think we have a couple um that that
could play
i think i'd i probably don't tell him i
i said this but i'd probably be jimmy
um as i could just see him as like a
wide receiver if he put on some way to
tight end i mean he's
six eight has unbelievable hands um and
he's just a
freak athlete strong fast um and
everything he i mean i'm i'm sure if you
ask him he probably thinks he can play
in the nfl tomorrow
um which is why i don't want him to know
that i just said that but i really i
really think we have a couple i think
bam
um and some other guys as well what's
that like though you hit six threes
last night when the ball leaves your
hand and you know it's going in
it's it's a good feeling um it's it's
good to see something go
obviously early on just kind of build
the confidence but uh
you know really my team my teammates and
my coaches have really kind of freed my
mind and that
they just want me to be aggressive so i
just try to do that game in a game out
do you ever
call it though duncan when it's in the
air do you say to your defender that's
good
sometimes if i'm kind of you know in
that in that zone
uh so to speak i think i have one last
night where um coming out of my hand
that i i just knew it was good sometimes
that happens
um it doesn't always happen but it's
nice when it does who was on you
uh that was the uh it was like kind of
like a late clock
daniel tyson like switched out and kind
of shot faked and
it just felt good coming out of my hand
so
you're two games from the fight you're
two wins from the finals
yeah it's uh it's crazy you know
when when you're entrenched in it it's
it's hard to kind of have the
perspective just because we're so
locked in on um you know playing prep
playing prep just day after day but uh
it's it's pretty incredible it's been an
incredibly fun journey
um we're loving it we don't want it to
end i know there's been a lot of talk
about
whatever how how tough the bubble's been
or this or that but
we we love it here we love being
together we love playing together and
we want to keep it rolling well you know
you told me recently that you can't wait
to uh
lock down lebron in the final so looks
like you'll you'll get your chance there
doug he's going to know your name
in the nba finals yeah we'll see we'll
see we got a long ways to go until then
uh we're focused on game three right now
i know well
we'll see by the way duncan didn't have
that quote i i made that uh
thank laker fans you wanted lebron you
got lebron
um congrats and uh good luck
thank you thank you very much i
appreciate you having me that's duncan
robinson the
heat forward guard great shooter
and he had six threes last night 18
points